now like I said I've mentioned a few
times Abbi is sort of anticipating where
we're going now if all of these are a
translation horizontally then what
happens if we actually have something
more like this have a look at what I've
put in here and I'm gonna start with a
parabola you'll see why in a second I
put a plus a on the right-hand side and
some people think of this as oh this is
gonna be my up-down movement right but I
want you to see this is actually not the
most helpful way to write it to make
that up-down movement obvious what's
that a really changing and the answer is
it's not changing X that plus a it
really belongs over on the left hand
side as a minus a right what this shows
you here you see the that a is not
attached to that X and it's not being
squared or anything like that this a
really belongs on the left hand side
with the Y this is a vertical change and
so you can see here if I go over now
let's come back to Des Moines I'm gonna
undo go back to squared there we go okay
what I've got over here I'm now going to
OH
get rid of back it's I don't need them
I'm gonna put this minus a on the left
hand side where I'm suggesting that it
belongs okay which I know some people
would say that seems like a weird place
to put it
let's have a look here right um let's
put that back to a value like this okay
yeah my stubby figures all right I'm
just gonna leave it there I'm satisfied
now what are we looking at here well
number one I hope you can see the
vertical change number two I hope you
can see we've moved upwards right do you
remember when we said X minus a it moves
you to the right even though it's a
minus a museum in the positive direction
well here why - a it's moving you
vertically but again it's moving you in
the positive direction the blue graph is
the new one the red one is the old one
so what's happening here we've moved up
a units in the positive direction so I'm
going to go ahead and I'm going to draw
that a parabola that I saw before it's
no longer intersecting down there at the
origin it's going to be all the way up
at a which in the case that we just true
was one point eight okay now in this
case just like in the very first
parabola that I
this could be a bunch of different
parabolas the scale is not apparent so I
need to choose some value and I need to
be able to put onto the graph and say oh
that's where I am that's where I'm
locked into this gives me a sense of the
scale okay now remember what we're
saying is this is the same graph that we
started with this one right up here y
equals x squared but we have moved
upwards eight units so you know how I
put this point here 2 comma 4 well if I
supply this same x value then the y
value should be moved up a units so if I
put in 2 as an x value I won't get 4 as
a y value I'll get 4 moved up a units so
4 plus a so what I can do is over here I
can say well that's going to be my
corner 2 comma 4 plus and you can go
ahead and verify this by putting in
let's find it right here by putting in x
equals 2 you're gonna get 2 squared plus
a that's the 4 plus a that we saw
earlier so you can get your point 4
scale from the previous graph as long as
you realize this is a movement upwards
okay um the same thing is going to
happen here I'm not even gonna go to
desmos because I'm convinced I know
what's going on here I have an upward
movement of a unit so that same cubic
shape that I saw earlier has been moved
up a units like so so this is going to
be a a and if I go ahead to try and find
my x intercept here I'm gonna let y
equal 0 so if I say y equals 0 try and
find an x intercept now I get 0 equals x
cubed plus a hmm
X cubed will therefore equal negative a
subtracting a from both sides and moving
things over onto the other side and so
if I want to find just X it's going to
be the cube root of negative a which
happens to also be the same as the
negative cube root of a so this is going
to be my new intercept and whatever
polynomial you are going to get it's
going to be that method of substituting
y equals 0 to get my x-intercept and
substituting x equals 0 to get my
y-intercept so let's go ahead and we
will mark that in okay now this is
now you can see like why did I leave
this one over here on the left-hand side
right well if I had y equals x plus a
this is following the pattern that I've
established over here on the right hand
side I am suggesting than a more helpful
way to think about this is to actually
put that a over on the left-hand side
right Y take away a equals x and what we
should have is a vertical change it's
gonna move up just like all the rest of
them a unit so let's try and thread the
needle through there there we go this is
gonna be my intercept at a and then
negative a down here in the bottom left
but a hold on a second isn't this the
same as the graph we were looking at
before but moved the other way right
well in the case of linear graphs a move
up or down actually is equivalent to a
move left or right you can actually see
it here you can imagine this as oh I
don't know if I didn't tell you what the
equation was you could have started from
y equals x and slid this over to the
left yeah so that would be the first way
of saying it look it's X plus a I've
moved to the left eight units
alternatively I can think about it the
way I've just explained oh this is a
graph that started with y equals x and
then I moved upwards so that would be a
way of thinking it like this the change
is really affecting the Y now it's
important that I mention this only
applies to linear functions every other
one like you can't say oh this this
parabola up here which moves to the
right it's kind of like a move upwards
it's a kind of equivalent well well it's
not equivalent is it it's it's left from
right and there's no way you can get to
this graph down here by moving any
amount left all right so with parabolas
cubics all the rest of the polynomials
left and right is different top down
right but it's because here on the left
hand side if you look at the algebra
this a can move left or right and affect
the x or y quite independently so I want
to make one final comment before I talk
any more about other transformations
we're gonna look at another one shortly
some of you have noticed right that when
you're moving now let's come back to
here when you're moving X minus a you go
the opposite direction to how you would
think right that - a moves you to the
right and when we're looking at vertical
that - a moves you up even though we
usually think of
- as down okay so something that you
might find helpful is that when I think
about this you might not think about
moving the graph instead and again if
this confuses you
leave it behind but if it's useful to
you like it has been to me then
hopefully it will be um something you
remember what I can really think about
is a different perspective when I see
that - a I can think about this as not
the graph but actually the coordinate
axes that are moving let me say that one
more time when I see this X minus a
instead of thinking about the graphed
moving left or right what I can think
about is the coordinate axes moving left
all right if you think think about where
their corner axes used to be right I'm
gonna put them into a different color
like this actually this gray will be
better there our coordinate axes right
use three positions so that the parabola
had its vertex right at the origin okay
so in other words putting it onto here I
mean used to look like this this is
where the corner axes used to be now you
can see the x-axis hasn't really gone
anywhere but the y-axis has the whole
thing has been moved think about where I
am now when you get rid of the x axis
because it hasn't changed the whole
thing has moved over to the left right
the whole axes have moved over a units
in fact and so when I see that - a I
think oh that is in the - direction but
it's not the graph that's changing its
the axes you can think about this in
exactly the same way for these guys
right for the vertical change when I see
this y minus a over here what I am
actually visualizing is everything on
the corner axes moves a units downwards
in the Y direction in the vertical right
so you can see where the axes used to be
they used to be here right going through
the origin but the axes I've got right
now they've moved downwards eight units
so if this is a better conceptual
framework for you to use to think about
rather than getting things backwards and
thinking oh - in this context means plus
in the other way and then maybe that's
something which you will find useful can
hold on to okay so this is translation
let me remind you that what we're
thinking about is left-right change if
your translation is on the
and you've got an up-down change if your
translation is on the WHI so look
carefully at where the algebra is and
that will tell you which direction the
graph moves in